just only four and a half hello anish
how are you hey where is the half coming
from
who are you are you the guy who comes up
with the titles
mashup will ask have you ever been to
kirk enough yes i have been to
kurgan hoof been there done that and
took a selfie actually
literally
what's up with the house just 24 and a
half what's up with the half
he's taking clips for the channel
yes i'm the one chosen before half is
the boy who clips it and ships at you
aneesh gear is streaming chest while
moving pieces with his right hand
streaming and opening his mouth and
saying words
okay let's click baity i'm gonna click
on that i think
anish giri silent for 20 seconds and
then says a word
oh that's nice only 20 seconds let me
click that hey
true he was silent i think i'm going to
click on the channel next time too
they don't lie oh also in
recommendations
magnus carlsen is throwing snowballs at
david howell
oh how interesting let me check that out
oh he really is throwing balls at david
howell how interesting
i think i'm gonna subscribe to this
channel
i started messing up the position but
already uh long after he was losing on
time
that's my excuse
he was throwing marshmallows huh was
throwing marshmallows maybe he was also
throwing snowballs
oh the play magnus corporation um we'd
have an idea
models next time you might throw
snowballs i think it's going to
deliver great content and david are you
ready
oh no you want to think you're ready for
it
i don't know david in fact as a matter
of fact really
i was just thinking about snowballs are
you ready for it
oh and guys we have magnus crossing with
us once again
so magnus are you happy with your
victory
not today